Bonjour à tous aujourd'hui
on va parler de ParcourSup.
Alors ParcourSup, vous le savez sans doute, c'est la procédure d'affectation
des élèves de Terminale aux formations
de l'enseignement supérieur :
les universités, les BTS, les classes prépas, etc.
L'idée de cette vidéo n'est pas
de vous donner des conseils d'orientation
mais plutôt d'évoquer
les mathématiques qui se cachent derrière Parcoursup
et notamment les fameux algorithmes d'affectation qui ont été beaucoup décriés et critiqués.
Comme il me semble que cette peur des algorithmes relève largement d'une méconnaissance
de ce qu'ils font vraiment et de comment ils le font,
aujourd'hui on va essayer de faire un peu
la lumière sur ce sujet controversé.
* Musique *
La question que Parcoursup
s'efforce de résoudre est assez ancienne
et très naturelle :
on a un certain nombre de futurs étudiants et un certain nombre de formations de l'enseignement supérieur
et on doit affecter les étudiants aux formations.
Evidemment on va pas faire ça au pif
puisque d'un côté les étudiants
ont des souhaits d'orientation,
des formations qu'ils préfèrent
et d'autres qui ne les intéressent pas
et de l'autre côté les formations, elles, ont des places limitées
et doivent donc appliquer des critères de sélection
pour choisir les étudiants qu'elles vont admettre.
Avant 2009 en France, il s'agissait d'un processus décentralisé : les étudiants prenaient contact
individuellement avec les formations qui les intéressaient.
Ils envoyaient un dossier et les formations leur disaient oui ou non.
Les étudiants devaient ensuite choisir parmi les formations auxquelles ils avaient été admis et donner une réponse.
Ensuite les formations avaient la possibilité de rappeler des candidats qu'elle avait mis provisoirement sur liste d'attente, et ainsi de suite.
Cette procédure décentralisée était franchement inefficace ça prenait un temps fou.
On faisait des allers-retours de courriers entre les formations et les étudiants
et c'était un casse-tête pour tout le monde.
D'un côté les formations devaient essayer d'anticiper la taille à donner aux listes d'admission et aux listes d'attente
pour éviter d'être en surnombre ou au contraire en sous-nombre à la fin.
Et de l'autre, les étudiants devaient parfois attendre des mois avant d'avoir une réponse.
Ce qui était stressant et pesait lourd notamment sur ceux qui devaient trouver un logement.
Et à la fin le résultat de l'affectation était loin d'être le meilleur possible.
Cette situation n'était évidemment pas spécifique de l'enseignement supérieur français
et par exemple dès les années 50, les formations médicales aux Etats-Unis se sont dit
qu'il fallait trouver un meilleur système. Ils ont alors imaginé une procédure groupée, centralisée
permettant d'affecter les internes en médecine aux différents hôpitaux du pays en fonction des choix des uns et des autres.
La première version de cette procédure était très simple. C'est une sorte d'affectation au fur et à mesure.
Dans cette procédure, tous les étudiants commencent par classer toutes les formations qu'ils visent par ordre de préférence.
On prend ensuite le premier choix de chaque étudiant.
On le soumet aux formations considérées qui décident alors pour chaque étudiant si elles l'acceptent ou pas.
Pour ceux qui ont été refusés, on passe alors à leur deuxième choix et on recommence.
Prenons un exemple concret :
Imaginons trois étudiants : Alice, Bob et Charlie et trois formations :  la fac de Lettres, celle d'Économie et celle de Sciences.
On va supposer pour simplifier que chaque formation n'a qu'une seule place.
Les étudiants classent les formations par ordre de préférence.
Disons qu'Alice préfère l'éco aux lettres et classe la fac de sciences en dernier.
Bob, lui, préfère les lettres à l'économie et les sciences en dernier aussi et Charlie pareil que Bob.
En face de ça les formations elles aussi ont des préférences c'est à dire que si elles reçoivent
simultanément plusieurs candidatures et bien elles devront choisir leur candidat préféré.
On va dire que la fac de lettres préférerait prendre Alice puis Charlie et en dernier Bob.
Celle d'économie son classement de préférence c'est : Bob, Alice, Charlie. Et la fac de sciences : Charlie, Alice puis Bob.
Simulons maintenant la procédure d'affectation :
les candidats postulent d'abord chacun à leur premier choix donc Alice en éco, Bob et Charlie en lettres.
La fac d'économie n'a reçu qu'une seule candidature celle d'Alice et donc l'accepte.
La fac de lettres, elle a le choix entre Bob et Charlie. Il n'y a qu'une place, on l'a dit.
Et elle choisit donc de prendre son préféré parmi les deux, c'est-à-dire Charlie.
A ce stade à la fin du premier tour, Bob s'est fait refuser et il est donc sans affectation.
On fait alors un deuxième tour où on regarde son deuxième choix : l'économie.
Sauf qu'il n'y a plus de place en éco puisque Alice a déjà été acceptée.
Donc Bob est contraint de postuler à son troisième choix, la fac de sciences
qui n'a reçu à ce stade que cette candidature est donc l'accepte.
A la fin, avec cette méthode, Alice va en économie, Charlie en lettres et Bob se retrouve en sciences.
Cette procédure d'affectation elle peut paraître assez raisonnable
notamment parce qu'elle vise à satisfaire au maximum les premiers choix,
ce que les étudiants ont mis tout en haut de leur liste.
Mais si on regarde dans le détail, elle a quand même quelques défauts.
Regardez Bob : à la fin il se retrouve en sciences qui était son dernier choix.
Mais au tour d'avant, il s'est fait refuser en éco parce que la fac d'éco avait déjà accepté Alice.
Sauf que la fac d'éco, si on regarde son classement initial et bien elle aurait préféré Bob à Alice.
Donc Bob a un peu de quoi être vénère, il s'est fait piquer la place en fac d'éco par quelqu'un
qui était moins bien classé que lui par cette formation. Il peut considérer qu'il s'est fait avoir par la procédure.
on dit que cette procédure n'est pas équitable c'est son premier défaut et donc ce qu'aurait dû faire bob pour éviter cette situation
c'est de la jouer tactique dès le départ plutôt que la fac de lettres même si c'est vraiment sincèrement ce qu'il aurait préféré faire
il aurait dû mettre éco en premier dans son classement
avec ça il aurait été admis au premier tour en éco ce qui aurait été mieux du moins à ses yeux que de finir en
sciences
pour optimiser ses chances bob aurait dû bricoler son classement initial
et en quelque sorte
mentir sur ses préférences réel en faisant une croix sur la fac de lettres sans savoir vraiment s'il avait une chance d'être pris ou pas
mais du coup si bob avait fait ça dès le départ
en refaisant la procédure vous pouvez vous convaincre que c'est alice qui aurait fini en sciences
et qu'à son tour elle aurait aussi pu trouver cela
inéquitable et avoir des regrets de ne pas avoir joué tactique par exemple en classant les lettres en premier
bref cette procédure d'affectation n'est finalement pas très satisfaisante car les étudiants sont incités à faire des calculs tactiques
pour essayer d'améliorer leur sort plutôt que d'être honnête et sincère sur leurs préférences
quand une situation de ce type se produit on dit que la procédure est
manipulable les étudiants peuvent tenter d'avoir mieux en ne la jouant pas sincèrement
ce qui a tendance à favoriser ceux qui ont les meilleures infos sur le fonctionnement du système aux dépens des autres
sachant en plus que tout ça est forcément basé sur des paris et des sacrifices
et que donc ça génère du stress et peut-être des regrets vous voyez donc que cette première procédure d'affectation
centralisée elle peut paraître au premier abord intéressante mais elle se révèle à la fois
inéquitable et manipulable la question évidemment c'est est-ce qu'on peut faire mieux
c'est à dire est ce qu'on peut trouver une procédure qui soit à la fois
équitable juste et qui en plus ne soit pas manipulable et bien oui et c'est ce qu'ont découvert en 1962 les deux mathématiciens
david gale et Lloyd Shapley. Pour expliquer la procédure de gale et shapley, le plus simple est de recourir à une analogie
imaginez que l'on ait un nombre identique d'hommes et de femmes et qu'on doivent les marier entre eux
comme c'est une analogie pour symboliser les étudiants et les formations on va chercher à faire que des mariages hétérosexuels
alors vous avez le droit de trouver ça restrictif et on reviendra justement sur cette hypothèse
pour appliquer la procédure inventée par gale et shapley chaque personne va d'abord classer les individus du sexe opposé par ordre de préférence
et à partir de ça on va chercher à créer les couples voici une illustration concrète
imaginons qu'on est trois hommes jon jaime et drogo et trois femmes daenerys cersei et brienne
voici le classement des individus du sexe opposé
supposons que Jon préfère Daenerys puis Brienne et en dernier Cersei
Jaime préfère aussi Daenerys mais ensuite Cersei puis Brienne et Drogo lui préfère Cersei puis Daenerys et enfin Brienne
et pareil pour les femmes chacune a son classement des trois hommes
quand on essaye de faire des couples avec ça évidemment tout le monde n'aura pas son premier choix
il y aura des frustrés ça c'est inévitable mais ce qu'on voudrait éviter de créer ce sont des situations
instables où on risque d'avoir des tentations d'adultère
regardez ici on a essayé de former les couples Jon - Daenerys
Jaime - Cersei et Drogo - Brienne ça paraît pas mal mais regardez
Drogo préférait être avec Daenerys plutôt qu'avec Brienne avec qui on l'associé et Denerys de son côté
préférerait aussi être avec Drogo plutôt qu'avec Jon dans cette configuration
Daenerys et Drogo se préfèrent mutuellement à leurs conjoints respectifs
ils vont donc avoir envie chacun de briser leur couple pour aller se mettre ensemble
la configuration de mariage qu'on a créé est donc instable
la question qu'on peut se poser en général c'est dans un problème d'union comme celui-ci avec potentiellement plein de participants
est-ce qu'on peut toujours trouver une configuration stable
intuitivement vous vous dites peut-être que oui ça paraît un peu évident qu'il doit exister une
configuration stable mais en fait non ça n'a rien d'évident a priori et pour le voir revenons sur l'hypothèse d'hétérosexualité
si on autorise tous les couples possibles homo comme hétéro on change le problème
cette fois-ci tout le monde classe tout le monde par ordre de préférence
on peut même oublier la notion de sexe et on essaye de former des couples là dedans
et bien là il n'existe pas toujours de configuration stable voici un exemple très simple avec seulement quatre personnes
Claude Sacha Dominique et Alex
supposons qu alex soit toujours classé en dernier par les trois autres. Personne n'en veut et qu'à côté on ait un triangle
claude préfère sacha à dominique, sacha préfère dominique à claude, et dominique préfère claude à sacha mais toujours alex en dernier
et bien là vous pouvez vous convaincre qu'il n'y a pas de configuration stable possible
celui ou celle qui se retrouve avec alex veut toujours se barrer et trouvera toujours dans l'autre couple quelqu'un qui est prêt à le rejoindre
Donc dans le cas de générique où tous les couples sont permis il peut donc parfois exister des situations sans solution stable
maintenant si on revient à notre cas où on se limite aux couples hétéros
la question qu'on se pose c'est donc de savoir si on peut toujours trouver au moins une configuration de mariage stable
et dans ce cas spécifique la réponse est oui. C'est ce qu'ont démontré en
1962 gale et shapley et pour ça ils ont fait ce qu'on appelle une démonstration
constructive ils ont trouvé une procédure qui permet à tous les coups de construire des mariages stable
pour expliquer cette procédure on va continuer à filer la métaphore du mariage
on a donc des hommes des femmes et chacun a son classement de préférence des individus du sexe opposé
on va faire une procédure en plusieurs tours où selon la tradition
les hommes proposent et les femmes disposent
alors voilà comment ça fonctionne au premier tour les hommes considèrent leur premier choix et lui font une proposition de mariage
sur notre exemple Jon propose à Daenerys, Jaime il propose aussi à Daenerys et Drogo propose à Cersei
ensuite chaque femme choisit son prétendants préféré parmi ceux qui sont proposés
Daenerys a le choix elle prend dont Jon qu'elle préfère à Jaime, Jaime se retrouve donc seul
Cersei n'a reçu qu'une seule proposition celle de Drogo donc elle l'accepte et Brienne n'a rien reçu
alors maintenant point essentiel : à ce stade de la procédure les femmes qui acceptent ne le font que de façon provisoire
ce sont des fiançailles si vous voulez dans l'attente
d'éventuellement trouver mieux à la fin de ce premier tour Jon est donc fiancé à Daenerys, Drogo à Cersei
brienne a personne et Jaime s'est fait rejeter
on fait alors un deuxième tour
où tous les hommes qui sont seuls
et uniquement eux
vont proposer à leurs choix suivant sur la liste
donc dans notre exemple il n'ya que Jaime qui soit tout seul
il s'est fait rejeter par Daenerys son premier choix
donc il propose à son second choix Cersei
les femmes vont alors à nouveau choisir leurs préférés parmi leurs prétendants
en ayant le droit de rompre leurs fiançailles
si elle on quelqu'un de mieux parmi ceux qui se proposent
ici justement Cersei a reçu une proposition de Jaime
qu'elle préfère à son engagement actuel avec Drogo
donc elle rompt les fiançailles
prendre Jaime
et Drogo se retrouve seul
et on recommence ainsi de suite
autant que nécessaire à chaque tour chaque homme seul propose à sa femme préférée parmi celles à qui il n'a pas encore proposé
et à chaque fois les femmes disposent en rompant leurs fiançailles si elles trouvent mieux
donc dans notre cas Drogo est maintenant seul, il a déjà proposé à Cersei donc il propose à son choix suivant Daenerys
Daenerys est actuellement avec Jon mais lui préfère dans ce cas la proposition de Drogo donc elle rejette Jon
au tour d'après Jon propose alors à son second choix Brienne qui accepte et là la procédure se termine car tout le monde est casé
Jon est finalement avec Brienne, Jaime avec Cersei et Drogo avec Daenerys
voici donc comment fonctionne la procédure de mariage de gale et shapley
je vous l'ai illustrée dans un cas très simple avec seulement trois couples mais ça se généralise
à autant que vous voulez il faut juste éventuellement faire plus de tours cette procédure vous trouvez peut-être qu'elle n'a rien de révolutionnaire
c'est relativement intuitif comme façon de faire est en effet c'est le cas
mais la principale contribution de gale et shapley ça a été de montrer deux choses
tout d'abord la procédure a
forcément une fin
on n'a pas des ruptures de fiançailles à l'infini on peut démontrer qu'au bout d'un moment ça s'arrête et tout le monde est casé
mais surtout deuxième propriété les couples formés à l'issue de la procédure sont stables au sens qu'ils ne vont pas engendrer des tentations d'adultère
regardez par exemple Jaime est avec Cersei il aurait préféré Daenerys mais celle-ci lui
vers son conjoint actuel Drogo donc pas de risque d'adultère
Brienne et avec Jon elle aurait préféré
Drogo ou même Jaime mais tous les deux l'ont classé derrière leur conjoint actuel pas de risque non plus
et vous pouvez tout vérifier comme ça ça marche la configuration est stable
puisque la procédure de Gale et Shapley peut toujours s'appliquer et fournit nécessairement une configuration stable et bien ça démontre qu'il en existe toujours une
ce qui n'était pas a priori
évident maintenant ce qu'on peut se demander c'est si la solution qu'on a fabriqué comme ça
et la seule solution stable ou s'il en existe d'autres
une chose que vous avez probablement remarqué c'est que la procédure de Gale et Shapley est asymétrique
elle fait jouer un rôle différent aux hommes et aux femmes
mais on pourrait très bien l'appliquer dans l'autre sens un les femmes proposent et les hommes disposent
vous pouvez vous amuser à le faire sur mon petit d'exemple voici ce que vous allez trouver comme couple à l'issue de la procédure
Daenerys avec Drogo, Cersei avec Jon et
Brienne avec Jaime c'est une solution stable aussi mais pas la même que tout à l'heure
et de façon générale quand on a beaucoup de couples il peut exister en fait plein de solutions stables
Gale et Shapley n'en donne qu'une, ou deux si vous l'appliquez dans les deux sens mais comparez un peu ces deux solutions
je vous représente ici à gauche les couples formés dans la procédure où les femmes proposent et à droite celle où les hommes proposent
Vous remarquez un truc ?
dans notre exemple quand les femmes proposent deux d'entre elles ont leur premier choix et la troisième a son second choix : pas mal
tandis que chez les hommes deux ont leurs derniers choix dans cette configuration stable les femmes sont carrément mieux lotis que les hommes
mais quand ce sont les hommes qui proposent leur situation est meilleure et celle des femmes au contraire moins bonne
clairement avec cette procédure il semblerait qu'il fallait mieux être dans le groupe qui propose et ça va même plus loin que ça
Gale et Shapley ont démontré que quand on est le groupe qui propose on obtient la meilleure solution qui soit parmi les solutions stables
impossible de faire mieux
malheureusement à l'opposé quand on est le groupe qui dispose
on obtient la pire solution possible parmi les solutions stables
alors je vous fais pas la démonstration
générique mais intuitivement on sent bien que si les hommes proposent
ils commencent avec leur premier choix et le dégradent progressivement
jusqu'à ce qu'on ait une solution stable alors que les femmes partent de ce qu'on leur propose et éventuellement progressent au cours de la procédure
donc la méthode est complètement inégalitaire entre les deux groupes elle privilégie clairement l'un au détriment de l'autre mais cela a un avantage indéniable
si vous êtes dans le groupe qui propose vous n'avez aucun intérêt à essayer de manipuler la procédure
en trichant sur vos préférences réelles par exemple, pas la peine de bidouiller, de faire des savants calculs, de la jouer stratégique
de toute façon en étant sincère
vous aurez déjà la meilleure solution que vous puissiez espérer. En conclusion la procédure de Gale Shapley a beau être extrêmement simple
elle possède plusieurs propriétés remarquables
comme le fait d'être non manipulable, de fournir une solution stable qui en plus est la meilleure possible pour le groupe qui propose
et puis surtout elle va extrêmement vite une fois qu'on dispose des classements de préférence des unes et des autres
c'est une simple simulation des différents tours de propositions qui se calculent quasi instantanément sur un ordinateur
on n'a pas besoin de redemander à chaque fois à tout le monde quelles propositions ils font ou ils acceptent tout est automatique à partir
des classements de préférence
bien alors maintenant arrêtons de parler de mariage arrangé de façon moyenâgeuse et revenons à nos problèmes d'étudiants et de formation
Pour affecter les étudiants à des formations on peut utiliser la procédure de Gale Shapley en disant que les étudiants sont les hommes et les
formations les femmes et la procédure nous permet de créer des appariements stables entre eux
dans ce contexte ça veut dire quoi stable
et bien ça veut dire qu'il n'y aura pas de jalousie
justifiée : un étudiant refusé dans une formation qui aurait à la place pris quelqu'un de moins bien classé
souvenez-vous tout à l'heure dans notre première procédure bob se retrouvait affecté à la fac de sciences alors qu'il aurait préféré la fac d'éco
sachant que la fac d'éco avait pris Alice mais aurait préféré bob à alice bob était en situation de jalousie justifiée
pour faire l'analogie avec le mariage et l'adultère la fac d'éco et bob préféreraient aller ensemble plutôt qu'avec leurs conjoints respectifs
donc une solution d'affectation stable c'est une solution sans ce genre de jalousie justifiée
alors justement appliquons la procédure de Gale Shapley en reprenant ce cas au départ au premier tour on regarde les premiers choix de chacun
alice propose à la fac d'éco tandis que bob et charlie proposent à la fac de lettres la fac d'éco accepte alice
provisoirement et la fac de lettres choisit son préféré charlie et l'accepte
provisoirement aussi bob est alors sans affectation à l'issue de ce premier tour
2e tour bob est tout seul donc il propose à son second choix la fac d'éco
comme l'affectation d'alice en éco était
provisoires comme des fiançailles et que la fac d'éco préfère justement bob et bien elle se sépare d'alice pour le prendre
alice se retrouve sur le carreau
troisième tour elle propose alors à son second choix la fac de lettres qui décide de la prendre à la place de charlie
charlie se retrouve sans affectation
quatrième tour charlie propose à son second choix la fac d'éco qui préfère garder bob
5e tour charlie propose alors à son troisième choix la fac de sciences qui l'accepte et la procédure se termine
alice va donc en lettres bob en éco et charlie en sciences et là on a une situation
stable sans jalousie
justifiée aucun élève ne peut se plaindre d'avoir été refusé quelque part où on aurait pris un candidat moins bien classé que lui
ça signifie que cette procédure d'affectation est juste, équitable
grâce à la propriété de stabilité. Alors deux petites précisions concernant l'application de cette procédure à des situations réelles
ici on a pris un cas simples où chaque formation n'avait qu'une seule place
mais la procédure se généralise sans problème au cas où chaque formation a plusieurs places, ce qui se produit toujours en pratique
est elle s'adapte aussi au cas où le nombre d'élèves et le nombre total de places disponibles ne seraient pas les mêmes
dans ce cas-là s'il y a trop d'élèves certains seront sans affectation à la fin et s'il n'y en a pas assez
certaines formations ne seront pas pleines. Un point extrêmement important de cette procédure on l'a dit c'est qu'elle n'est pas manipulable
dans la mesure où les élèves obtiennent la meilleure affectation possible parmi les affectations stables ils n'ont aucun intérêt à la jouer stratégique
pour tenter d'améliorer leur situation
pas de ruse ou de bricolage pas d'avantage à ceux qui seraient mieux informés ou plus malins il suffit d'être sincère et honnête
et donc pas de stress d'avoir fait le mauvais choix. En conclusion vous voyez que la procédure d'affectation de Gale Shapley combine plein d'avantages
elle fournit une solution stable donc équitable, sans jalousie
justifiée, elle assure la meilleure solution pour les étudiants, du moins parmi les solutions stables, et elle n'est pas manipulable
donc pas de calcul ni de stratégie
en plus de ça elle est simple et transparente
on peut comprendre exactement ce qui s'est passé et pourquoi dans telle ou telle formation on n'a pas été pris
contrairement à ce qu'on entend parfois ça n'est pas du tout une procédure opaque une sorte d'IA qui vous affecterait sans que vous compreniez pourquoi
non non on peut parfaitement
reconstituer le raisonnement, et enfin la procédure de Gale Shapley est quasi instantanée une fois que tout le monde a fait sa liste de préférences
aussi bien les étudiants que les formations on simule les tours successifs de proposition dans un ordinateur
et on a très vite la réponse pour tout le monde sur le papier cette procédure semble avoir quasiment tous les avantages
malgré tout il faut que je mentionne une petite limite de cette méthode la solution obtenue est certes la meilleure parmi les solutions stables
mais ça n'est pas forcément la meilleure dans l'absolu
il y a des cas où on peut trouver une solution encore meilleure en sacrifiant la stabilité
regardez mon exemple initial avec alice bob et charlie on l'a vu la procédure de Gale Shapley a
affecté Alice en lettres, bob en éco et charlie en sciences
regardez spécifiquement alice et bob
alice est en lettres mais préfèrerait l'éco, bob est en éco mais préfèrerait lettre, eh bien ils n'ont qu'à échanger leur place
si on fait ça la solution qu'on obtient être encore meilleure elle donne plus de
satisfaction à alice et bob et ne dégrade pas la situation de charlie mais elle pose un problème
charlie se retrouve alors en situation de jalousie justifiée
il peut légitimement se plaindre que bob soit pris en lettres alors que lui charlie se trouvait beaucoup mieux classé que lui
on a trouvé une solution meilleure
mais instable
donc
inéquitable
ce petit exemple illustre
un des paradoxes de ces questions d'affectation
la meilleure solution possible
n'est pas forcément stable
et donc pas forcément juste
en utilisant la procédure de Gale Shapley on choisi de privilégier la stabilité
et donc l'équité de la procédure
on pourrait utiliser une autre méthode qui privilégie le fait de trouver la meilleure solution en sacrifiant l'équité si nécessaire
ça existe ça s'appelle la procédure du cycle d'échange optimale elle a été imaginée aussi par david Gale
et on l'utilise notamment pour des questions d'affectation dans le cas du don d'organes
cette procédure sacrifie l'équité au profit de l'optimalité
mais entre ça et Gale Shapley il n'existe pas de procédure qui permette d'avoir à la fois l'un et l'autre il faut faire un choix
on l'a dit, Gale Shapley trouve la meilleure solution parmi les solutions stables, ce qui est déjà remarquable
et c'est ce qui explique que c'est plus ou moins cette procédure qui est utilisée dans de nombreux pays qui pratiquent une affectation
centralisée des choix
par exemple les internes en médecine aux états unis dont on a parlé ou encore les études supérieures en allemagne en italie en turquie en
tunisie au chili etc
et bien évidemment c'est aussi cette procédure qui est à l'origine de la méthode utilisée en france entre 2009 et 2017 :
la procédure apb pour admission postbac
Dans la procédure apb tout commence par le classement que les étudiants établissent ils choisissent au maximum 24 formations qui les intéressent
et les classe par ordre de préférence
l'idée d'apb et
d'appliquer une procédure de Gale Shapley
c'est à dire un calcul ou à partir de ces listes de préférences
on calcule automatiquement une solution stable
pour que la procédure puisse s'appliquer il faut donc aussi évidemment
que les formations classent les étudiants
et c'est là que ça se complique
il y a en france deux grands types de formations post bac
d'un côté les formations dites sélectives comme les bts classes prépas iut
qui traditionnellement classent et sélectionnent leurs candidats
selon des critères qui leur sont propres c'est une grosse moitié de l'offre de formation et de l'autre on a les licences universitaires
qui sont des formations dites non sélective c'est à dire qu'elles n'ont légalement pas le droit de sélectionner leurs étudiants
du moins pas sur des critères scolaires
historiquement c'est l'article 14 de la loi du 26 janvier 1984
le premier cycle est ouvert à tous les titulaires du baccalauréat
tout candidat est libre de s'inscrire dans l'établissement de son choix
les dispositions relatives à la répartition entre les établissements et les formations exclut toute sélection
donc en France à partir du moment où on a le bac
on a accès à l'enseignement universitaire
et donc le droit de s'inscrire en licence
peu importe nos notes notre filière d'origine
la sélection est interdite
pour beaucoup de licences universitaires ça ne pose pas de problème particulier
car le nombre de places est suffisant pour accueillir toutes celles et ceux qui le souhaitent
mais pour certaines filières très demandés comme le droit la psycho les études de santé ou encore staps du fait que chaque étudiant peut proposer
24 choix dans apb on se retrouve avec plus de candidats que de places disponibles
on dit que ces licences sont "en tension"
est donc d'une façon ou d'une autre ces licences universitaires doivent trouver un moyen de classer les étudiants
afin qu'on puisse appliquer la procédure de Gale Shapley
sauf qu'ils n'ont pas le droit de le faire en tout cas pas sur des critères scolaires
pour résoudre ce problème des licences en tension apb avaient recours automatiquement à trois critères successifs
premièrement on regarde l'académie d'origine et on donne priorité aux étudiants locaux on peut discuter l'idée mais elle n'est pas forcément absurde,
pourquoi pas. Ensuite pour départager les étudiants de la même académie
on regarde en quelle position ils ont classé cette formation dans leurs voeux
l'idée derrière c'est que mettez-vous à la place d'une de ces formations disons staps
vous avez le choix entre quelqu'un qui a classé staps en premier choix et quelqu'un qui l'a classé en troisième choix
eh bien vous avez envie de donner priorité à celui qui l'a classé en premier
on favorise ceux qui veulent vraiment cette formation ça paraît assez naturel et relativement juste dit comme ça mais en fait
c'est une entorse énorme au principe de Gale Shapley et ça pose de gros problèmes à apb
en principe dans la procédure de Gale Shapley tout le monde établit son classement de façon honnête et objective
sans tenir compte de ce que font les autres or quand pour une licence en tension on utilise les critères que je viens d'exposer
c'est comme si chaque formation attendait d'avoir le classement des étudiants pour établir le sien en fonction et
favoriser les étudiants qui l'ont classé en premier
donc on rompt la logique de la procédure de Gale Shapley et le souci que ça pose c'est que ça la rend manipulable
imaginez que votre classement sincère ce soit disons classes préparant premier et en deux staps
mais que vous sachiez qu'il y a un risque de ne pas être pris en prépa en principe avec la procédure de Gale Shapley
vous pouvez sans risque être sincère et donner ce classement-là : prépa puis staps
mais avec un système comme apb il ya un risque que d'abord la prépa vous refuse
et ensuite que staps vous refuse aussi car vous ne l'avez pas classé en premier et donc vous êtes complètement perdant
ce qu'il faudrait faire dans le doute c'est faire une croix sur la prépa sans jamais savoir si vous auriez eu vos chances
et mettre staps en premier pour assurer le coup
donc on se retrouve avec les défauts du tout premier système que j'avais présenté
pour réussir il faut jouer tactique et mentir dans son classement sans savoir si on a fait le bon calcul
ce qui est quand même un peu stressant et favorise ceux qui  connaissent le mieux le système
et c'est d'autant plus grave qu'apb incitait  justement à être sincère en disant dans son guide je cite
vous pouvez modifier le classement de vos demandes de formation par ordre de préférence et sans autocensure
et bien non si vous suiviez ce conseil il y avait un certain risque de se faire avoir ça c'est le premier gros problème d'apb
deuxième problème même en prenant en compte cette manière de départager il reste encore parfois des ex-aequo pour certaines licences très demandées
et là pour sélectionner la procédure apb avait recours tout simplement à un tirage au sort
en 2017 ça s'est produit pour une centaine de licences et le tirage au sort a concerné près de soixante mille candidats
un exemple parmi d'autres cette année là il y avait en ile-de-france pour la paces l'ex première année de médecine
8507 candidats ayant tous classés cette formation en choix numéro un
ils étaient donc tous ex-aequo mais il n'y avait que sept mille six cent cinquante places il a donc fallu tirer au sort pour éliminer
857 étudiants chaque étudiant avait donc en gros une chance sur 10 de se faire refuser et ce indépendamment de tout critère pédagogique
finalement ça a fait scandale
on a trouvé une solution au dernier moment pour admettre tout le monde mais cela a précipité la chute d'apb
et la mise en place en 2018 d'une nouvelle plateforme Parcoursup
Le fonctionnement de parcoursup est dans les grandes lignes identique à celui d'apb mais avec plusieurs changements importants
tout d'abord plus de tirage au sort et pour cela toutes les formations reçoivent elles-même
le droit de classer les candidats sur des critères scolaires y compris les licences universitaires en tensions
qui peuvent de fait sélectionner leurs étudiants sur la base de leurs notes de leurs filières etc
autre changement important
cette fois les formations ne peuvent plus utiliser
les classements faits par les candidats pour favoriser ceux qui auraient classé la formation au premier rang comme c'était le cas dans apb
et si ça ça n'est plus possible
c'est tout simplement parce que les candidats ne classent plus leurs choix ils font une liste de voeux des formations qui les intéressent
mais ils ne font pas de classement de hiérarchisation
à première vue c'est plutôt avantageux pour les étudiants ça leur laisse le temps de la réflexion, de mûrir leur projet d'orientation
ils ne doivent plus dès le départ décider de classer toutes les formations ce qui n'est pas forcément si évident plusieurs mois avant la rentrée
et sans savoir s'ils ont leur chance donc la suppression de cette hiérarchisation des voeux par les candidats ça paraît plutôt une bonne chose
sauf que ça pose un gros problème de fonctionnement de la procédure
avec apb on avait toutes les préférences dès le départ
donc on pouvait calculer les affectations en
simulant avec un ordinateur les différents tours de
propositions de la procédure de Gale Shapley
et ça allait très vite, seulement quelques minutes de calcul
avec parcoursup les candidats ne classent plus d' avance et donc voici ce qui se passe
les étudiants ont fait leurs voeux sans classement les formations reçoivent la liste des étudiants qui les ont choisis et doivent les classer entre eux
en fonction de ça les formations renvoient aux étudiants une réponse ça peut être oui dans ce cas ils sont admis s'ils le souhaitent
en attente ils sont sur liste d'attente ou bien non s'ils sont refusés. Alors cette dernière possibilité c'est uniquement pour les formations sélectives
dans une licence universitaire même si vous êtes classé dernier vous serez sur liste d'attente
les étudiants doivent alors impérativement donner une réponse aux formations qui leur ont dit oui ils ont quelques jours pour le faire
l'idée c'est comme les fiançailles c'est d'accepter la formation qu'on préfère parmi celles qui nous ont répondu favorablement et donc
refuser les autres pour libérer les places
c'est donc seulement à ce moment là que les étudiants doivent réfléchir à la hiérarchisation de leurs voeux et uniquement entre les réponses positives
ce qui est plus facile et évidemment si on dit oui à une formation c'est comme les fiançailles c'est provisoire
ça ne nous empêche pas d'accepter plus tard une autre formation qui nous aurait initialement mis sur liste d'attente.
comme des places se libèrent une fois que les candidats ont répondu
un deuxième tour s'enclenche et les formations peuvent refaire des propositions donc dire oui à certains de ceux qui étaient sur liste d'attente
et on recommence les formations proposent et à chaque fois les étudiants doivent réfléchir et répondre à force d'aller retour en principe ça finira par
converger vers une solution stable
donc ce qu'il se passe en pratique avec ce système c'est qu'au lieu de résoudre tout d'un coup dans un ordinateur
on se retrouve à reproduire grandeur nature à la main les différents tours de propositions de la procédure de Gale Shapley
alors première observation vous l'aurez peut-être noté : dans cette procédure les formations proposent et les élèves disposent
vous souvenez de ce que ça signifie la procédure converge vers la meilleure solution possible
pour ceux qui proposent donc ici les formations et par contre pour ceux qui disposent ici les élèves on obtient la pire solution
possible parmi les solutions stables en bref on favorise les formations au détriment des élèves
en ce n'est peut-être pas si grave car il semblerait qu'en pratique il n'y est pas tant de différences que ça entre les deux solutions
mais sur le principe c'est un peu choquant enfin c'est pas le pire
le principal souci avec parcoursup c'est que chaque aller-retour peut prendre presque une semaine
et donc pour arriver au bout de la procédure et que chacun reçoive son affectation ça dure des mois
à comparer aux quelques minutes que prenait le calcul d'apb
et oui parce qu'apb souvenez vous on avait d'avance le classement des voeux des candidats là on
redemande à chaque fois à tous les étudiants ce qu'ils préfèrent pour choisir parmi les réponses positives
évidemment toute cette attente qui dure des mois génère beaucoup de stress pour les étudiants qui doivent sans cesse
consulter la plateforme pour voir si leur situation bouge s'ils ont reçu de nouvelles propositions
à tel point que l'accès à parcoursup est complètement bloqué pendant les épreuves du bac pour éviter de trop perturber les élèves de terminale
alors oui en théorie le fait de ne pas hiérarchiser les voeux donne beaucoup plus de liberté
aux étudiants pour mûrir leur projet mais il faut pas se leurrer non plus on sait très bien qu'en pratique beaucoup
d'étudiants finiront par craquer et abandonner c'est à dire qu'ils accepteront définitivement une formation qui n'aurait pas été leur premier choix
par lassitude d'être sur liste d'attente et d'être dans le stress et l'incertitude de ne pas savoir ce qu'ils vont devenir
finalement on a un peu l'impression d'être revenu aux procédures décentralisées qui existaient avant même apb et qui étaient longues stressantes et
inégalitaire à part la lenteur on peut mentionner un autre défaut de parcoursup le fait qu'il n'y ait plus de hiérarchisation des voeux
limite grandement la possibilité de faire des statistiques
avec un système comme apb on pouvait estimer à la fin quel pourcentage des étudiants
avaient eu leur premier choix ou combien il aurait fallu de places dans chaque formation pour que tout le monde soit content avec
parcoursup on ne connaît jamais ce qui aurait été le premier choix des étudiants
donc on perd un outil d'évaluation du fonctionnement du système alors avec tout ce que je viens de dire on peut se demander légitimement
pourquoi cette apparente régression liée au fait de ne plus hiérarchiser les voeux
et bien il y a je crois plusieurs bonnes raisons et une mauvaise
parmi les bonnes on l'a vu il y a le fait de donner plus de temps aux étudiants pour réfléchir bon ok
autre avantage indéniable de cette non hiérarchisation c'est le nouveau dispositif appelé "oui si", qui permet aux formations
d'accepter une étudiante ou un étudiant
sous réserve qu'ils ou elles suivent une formation complémentaire et ça ce serait compliqué à prendre en compte dès le départ avec une hiérarchisation
parce qu'on peut imaginer qu'un élève soit très intéressé par une formation
mais beaucoup moins intéressé si par exemple celle-ci lui demande un rattrapage préalable et enfin dernière innovation
positif de parcoursup c'est le fait pour les formations de pouvoir prendre en compte un quota minimum de boursiers et un quota maximum
d'étudiants hors académie et la prise en compte de ces quotas se fait de façon automatique
à partir des classements établis par les formations grâce à l'algorithme conçu par les chercheurs Claire Mathieu et Hugo Gimbert
au total je ne sais pas si ces avantages justifient le stress supplémentaire engendré par la non
hiérarchisation des voeux mais je crois surtout que derrière les spécifications de parcoursup il y a aussi une mauvaise raison, plus politique
une des choses qui a notamment sonner le glas d'apb c'est un avis rendu en 2017 par la cnil la commission nationale informatique
et liberté cet avis concernait spécifiquement apb et il a interdit le recours au tirage au sort ce qu'on peut largement comprendre
mais il a aussi imposé une intervention humaine dans le traitement des dossiers en interdisant une affectation
purement basée sur l'emploi d'algorithmes
alors je n'ai aucun doute sur le fait que les gens de la cnil sachent très bien de quoi ils parlent
mais cet avis a été utilisé pour enterrer apb en accusant ainsi les
algorithmes et cela relève me semble-t-il surtout d'une entourloupe et d'une confusion
on l'a vu il y avait de vrais problèmes avec apb
mais la méthode de base la procédure de Gale Shapley est parfaitement efficace et adaptée pour peu qu'on l'applique correctement
alors oui cette procédure est ce qu'on peut appeler un algorithme même si vous noterez que j'ai fait exprès d'éviter ce mot
si les étudiants et les formations ont renseigné leur classement correctement alors on a un gros calcul informatique qui se fait de façon automatique
et fournit en sortie la liste des affectations en quelques minutes c'est un algorithme qui tourne sur un ordinateur
mais la procédure est parfaitement connue transparente et explicable à n'importe quel élève de terminale en tout cas j'espère avoir réussi à le faire
et en principe chacun devrait pouvoir vérifier et comprendre le pourquoi de son affectation
contrairement à ce qu'on a pu entendre apb n'était pas un algorithme opaque, une boîte noire, une sorte d'intelligence artificielle
qui déciderait pour vous de votre avenir sans que vous n'y compreniez rien
d'ailleurs à la fin avec parcoursup on a reproduit presque exactement la même procédure d'affectation
qu'APB le même algorithme mais avec plein d'allers retours entre les étudiants et les formations au lieu d'un truc automatique
conséquence ça prend des mois mais ce délai presque totalement
artificielle a comme effet secondaire de rassurer les gens en enlevant cette impression qu'un ordinateur central décide en quelques secondes pour tout le monde
on donne l'impression de rendre du libre arbitre
d'ailleurs voici ce que disait un responsable du ministère dans une interview au blog ingénu-ingénieur
"l'idée avec parcours sud c'était de mettre en place un nouveau système
fondé sur la transparence et la liberté de choix pour les candidats avec apb c'était les algorithmes qui faisaient la loi"
quand on lit ça on a vraiment l'impression qu'APB c'était de la magie noire
alors que je le répète le principe d'affectation était essentiellement le même qu'avec parcoursup mais à
avec parcoursup c'est très très ralentie
en gros un des bénéfices de cette procédure super lente c'est d'enlever cette impression qu'un algorithme décide pour vous de votre avenir
même si le résultat final est presque le même et je pense que c'était clairement l'intention
évidemment en tant que vulgarisateur scientifique ça me frustre de voir qu'on se retrouve dans cette situation
tendue parce qu'on n'a pas été capable d'expliquer comment marche la procédure
ce qu'est un algorithme et pourquoi algorithmes et bien c'est pas synonyme d'un truc démoniaque et arbitraire
d'ailleurs pour bien poser le débat il est probablement utile de faire une distinction importante
entre les algorithmes d'appariement et ceux de classement des étudiants
dans apb l'algorithme d'appariement c'était Gale Shapley qui marche très bien on l'a vu
et l'algorithme de classement pour les licences en tension c'était cette suite de critères
academie d'origine, rang du voeux, et enfin tirage au sort on voit bien que ce qui n'allait pas du tout c'était la partie classement la procédure
d'appariement marchait très bien or le passage à parcoursup a modifié les deux
il a remplacé la partie classement par une vraie procédure de sélection basée sur des critères pédagogiques
avec une intervention humaine ce qui va plutôt dans le bon sens  même si ça manque encore de transparence sur les critères
et en ce qui concerne la procédure d'appariement parcoursup a gardé
essentiellement la même chose qu'apb mais super ralenti du fait qu'il n'y a plus de hiérarchisation des voeux
et ça ça n'est pas du tout la faute de ceux qui ont conçu l'algorithme le fait de ne plus
hiérarchiser les voeux était une spécification très claire du ministère et franchement on peut se demander si les bénéfices justifiaient ce choix
une façon de faire qui permettrait de retenir les avantages de la non hiérarchisation tout en évitant trop d'attente et de stress
ce serait de limiter la période pendant laquelle les candidats ne classent pas les voeux ça n'a rien d'extraordinaire
c'est par exemple exactement ce qui se passe en allemagne avec la procédure DOSV
les étudiants font une liste de voeux sans classement les formations répondent et au bout d'un délai de 1 mois
les étudiants sont obligés de faire une hiérarchisation
donc on sait qu'au bout d'un mois d'attente maximum la hiérarchisation des voeux permettra un traitement
automatique accéléré et le système convergera et proposera rapidement des affectations définitives
ça permet aussi de s'assurer que le moins de gens possible vont rester sur le carreau
alors qu'avec le système actuel en france on peut se retrouver à
rappeler des gens à la fin de l'été parce qu'une place s'est finalement libérée etc
bien sûr je ne dis pas qu'il faille saborder parcoupsup pour tout reprendre à zéro mais on peut espérer qu'au fil des années
des améliorations de ce type seront ajoutées pour rendre le système plus juste plus transparent et plus efficace
voilà c'est tout pour cette vidéo qui vous aura un peu changé de la science pure et dure
comme toujours il y a pas mal de détails de compléments et de sources dans le billet de blog qui accompagne la vidéo n'hésitez pas
à les lire si vous avez aimé la vidéo n'oubliez pas de mettre un pouce vous abonner la cloche tout ça
les actus de la chaîne ça se passe sur facebook et twitter et on se retrouve prochainement pour une nouvelle vidéo à bientôt